it's been a struggle for Americans
looking to buy a home over the last few
years home ownership Belinelli
sixty-five percent at the end of 2014 to
the lowest reading since 1994 but could
there be a housing turnaround for those
first-time homebuyers with me now to
discuss market makers Erik schatzker is
there well Alex there are some trends
shall we say favoring the first time
home buyer and the first time home buyer
is so to speak the problem here fewer
than thirty percent of previously owned
and sold homes in 2014 went to
first-time homebuyers twenty-nine
percent in fact is the official figure
the lowest since the national
association of realtors began tracking
this data back in two thousand eight and
why is it so difficult for these people
to buy homes with your mom and dad well
they're young they tend to be young
people young couples most of the time
they've got a lot of student debt for
example credit conditions remain tight
the underwriting standards that the
banks are demanding remain tight so it's
harder for these people to get loans
than it was before 2008 but several
things have happened that may allow that
percentage to rise among them the
federal government has dropped a 3-2 at
a minimum of three percent the amount of
money the limit on what you have to put
down in order to get a federally insured
mortgage now that's not that three
percent down payment isn't available for
all mortgages but it does give you a
sense of where it is down to three from
ten there are there's a smaller mortgage
insurance premium being charged by the
FHA for example that applies to people
with lower credit scores and of course
the economy has picked up some steam and
there is the unemployment rate has
dropped obviously there's wage growth we
have it I'm sorry there are jobs being
created we haven't seen the wage growth
that's a big question mark yeah three
percent seems a lot closer to zero
percent down payment and the ten percent
that other homebuyers are seen as a huge
rent it raises the most important
question of all which is should we be
trying to incentivize more home
ownership if you goes the funny that the
percentage of Americans owning homes
does the fact that it has dropped say
something bad about America or bad about
the American economy or bad about the
way the economy has been
managed I don't know quite honestly but
here are some things to consider if you
buy a home you are stuck with a very
illiquid asset right to begin with you
are highly leveraged you are at the very
least highly indebted and you are if
you're boring with a three percent down
payment highly leveraged if the house
drops by if I have the value of the home
drops by three percent right you're
underwater and finally it creates this
illusion of wealth when people's home
values rise they tend to feel good about
spending they borrow more that's not
necessarily agree with an idea